[Music]
[Applause]
i have this uh this was sent to us i
asked mark cuban he's been fined so many
times by the nba and i said could you
send me one of the letters you get
and uh you know it's got his name
delivered by uh fedex october 8th of
2004 he had said something about uh
training camp rules and they said uh
you're hereby 100 000
please remit this some to the nba no
later than friday october 22nd 2004.
please be advised that further conduct
of this kind will subject you to
additional penalties
been fined a few few times mark cuban
the uh mavs owner he's going to be on
home economics tonight that's at 9 30
eastern on abc i'm just mentioning mark
you've been fined so many times
and uh you made some comments on dr j's
podcast about tanking uh
what was the last time you got fined
what was that for
the one you got there was was really
well deserved because i got fined
because i said it was crazy
that we couldn't have played um
potential draftees five on five we could
only play them three on three and that
made absolutely no sense
but they do you have to write them a
check and then you send it to the home
office
no i refuse to do that they deducted
from something else
okay my goal is for you not to get fined
today how's that my goal's not to be
fined as well
do you remember the first time you saw
luca play
um yeah
i watched a video of him playing against
the thunder and what russell westbrook
when he was 17.
okay and then what happens right after
that
the gate you know it was obvious the kid
could play and so then it was a question
of
okay you know will we be able to draft
him where will our draft slot be and we
had the third worst record and ended up
with the fifth pick the mavs have never
moved up from our slot ever in the
history of the franchise and then from
there it was how we going to figure this
out because we really want the kid okay
but how do you send out mixed signals or
mixed messages not to chip your hand
that you're in love with uh luca
you don't i mean it's inevitable it's
really about what do the teams ahead of
us in the draft want to do
you know so it was number one deandre
ayton number two you know we didn't know
what the sacramento kings were going to
do
and we thought that um
it was number three um the hawks and the
number four the grizzlies and so we felt
like if the hawks didn't pick him the
grizzlies would and he was no way he was
making it down to five so we had to
trade up somehow some way and literally
it ended up with me on the phone with
the owner of the hawks like 15 minutes
before our pick was getting done
we had to make or they had to make their
pick at three
working out a trade together
it's just amazing that when i watched
him when he was playing in europe he
always seemed like he was just fast
enough
just quick enough just able to get his
shot off and i thought if he's just able
to do that playing against those players
i had doubts that he could
be a you know a guy who dominates like
he has been what what is it about he
moves at his own pace it's it's like
kawhi leonard they have a different
speed and it's different than everybody
else's
yeah and quite a good analogy because
quite quite's got size obviously and
he's strong and you know koi's got the
hands and the length and everything but
they're able to see the game at their
own speed and use their physicality to
get where they want to go on the court
and the other thing that luca adds to
that is his ball handling you know when
somebody's got the handles that luca has
and the size not only can you see things
and make passes and you know play the
five level chest that he plays on the
court
but um you can get to places on the
court at your own speed because of the
handles and the physicality people don't
realize how big he is until you stand
next to him you know if you put him up
against the biggest
nfl linebackers luke is going to be
bigger
if
you know you start to look at this and
he's had an unbelievable season second
half of the season has been unbelievable
if not him for mvp who would you vote
for
um i mean there's probably a group of
three with um jokic embiid
maybe book um
you know those those would probably be
my top three i'm sure i'm leaving
somebody out off the top of my head but
you know obviously i put luca right
there with them okay but who would you
pick instead yeah if i had to i'd
probably say jokic just because you know
he lost two prime players and he's
basically carried that team
he's mark cuban the mavs owner joining
us um if you i don't know how often you
get advice or give advice to
billionaires who think about buying a
franchise when's the last time a
billionaire called and said i'm thinking
about
i don't i mean i don't qualify their
their um
net worth before i talk to them but i
get i get called every now and then from
people who are in a position to buy
franchises
okay but if you were going to give
advice what would you tell somebody who
had a lot of money
be the majority owner not the minority
owner
that that's the key because then it's
your franchise if you're a minority
owner or you've got too big a group then
it it just becomes um
just a regular company it's not your
baby there's just a big difference
do you have to love the team you're
buying
depends on who you are i mean me yes but
if it's a business deal no you know if
you're looking at this purely as a
business acquisition no you don't have
to to love it you can run it to win it
still you can love basketball but if you
know there's going to be people who
prioritize business over passion
but also you were buying the mavs and
you're not from dallas
so no but i've been in dallas since
1982. okay you know when i bought into
in 2000 i was a season ticket holder and
been there 20 years and had been going
to every game for years you think you'll
ever buy another team
no no chance
yeah yeah just it just it's such an
emotional commitment you know when i
first got into the mavs i was looking at
a baseball team and um considered it and
then as my kids got older you know they
were too much fun and i realized the
emotional commitment i kind of was um
i was spoiled because of dirk you know
it seemed kind of easy because i had
dirk there and we were winning 50-plus
games every year and competing and you
know you realize
over a period of time that it's just
such an emotional commitment that it's
it's hard it you know i couldn't imagine
you know having had purchased a baseball
team and doing this for another 162
games if rob manfred the commissioner
major league baseball came on shark tank
and wanted you to invest in that product
not a team
the sport itself
what would you say
i would say with some changes i would i
think baseball is well suited for the
tick tock generation
because you it comes in small bites you
know and using a tick tock like ai
driven approach you could um create an
application where you know your fit your
you know you could be living in dallas
and be a rangers fan but if a hot um
came up or your favorite player came up
you could just you know you'd have an
app where you'd be swiping in you know
those plate appearances or those pitches
where anytime someone was you know in a
close game there's so many ways that
baseball could use technology to present
the game that they don't and then i
would also push to speed the game up
like no throwing the ball around the
horn you know i would i would
go away from some of the traditions i
would make my the players do bat flips
you know engage them on the bla
things that you know might get the ball
thrown at you but you'd have to talk to
the players first to say look you know
if we want to change this game and get
kids excited again we're going to have
to make changes and i i you know the
stuff that they did you know putting a
runner on second base seven hitting
double headers to me that was just
really ridiculous yeah i just don't know
the direction baseball's going in it
feels like every other sport
has figured it out or at least they're
moving in the the escalator is going up
right i don't know where baseball is
going it feels like it's either stopped
or it's it's heading down a little bit
yeah i mean it's tough for them because
it's an older an older fan base it's not
really built for prime time for
traditional social media if there is
such a thing right the highlights aren't
as compelling they're not as athletic as
say the nfl or the nba
um and so that that kind of plays
against them
so you've got to adjust but like i said
you know they're better suited to a
tick-tock like presentation in in
parallel with um
linear linear presentations of the game
right so you can you know for those who
like who love baseball want to watch all
nine innings you do your traditional
linear presentation but you could have a
three dollar a month or a five dollar a
month feed that's kind of like red zone
for major league baseball that's geared
towards you know algorithmically driven
presentation of your favorite players
and teams and circumstances and i think
that type of thing is better suited for
baseball but will happen in all sports
okay it seems obvious to you why isn't
that obvious to baseball
that's a mystery i've never been able to
follow
what does it say about basketball that
the best players in the game or amongst
the best players in the game are from
europe they're not american-born what it
used to be that was sort of a negative
you were soft you were sort of
one-dimensional uh
but now we look at it and uh i don't
know if it was dirk or kim elijah who
started this but uh how do you make
sense of that
well there's a lot more people in the
rest of the world than there are in the
united states and basketball to david
stern's credit has become a global game
you know when you've got you know tens
of millions of basketball players
globally you know your the percentage is
going to be lower than it is in the
united states but at the same time
you're going to the stars are the ones
that come through and come over and play
here
uh home economics you're making uh you
made your debut with uh abc fill us in
on your cameo
yeah it was fun it was it turned out
that it ended up being more than just a
cameo i got to hang out with all the
guys and um it really was a fun episode
so it's tonight on abc check it out my
acting chops are stellar um and and it
really is a fun episode uh what's on the
t-shirt that you have oh this is my um
crypto dirk my meta mavs legend um every
every home game um the mavs give out an
nft to everybody who comes and scans
their ticket before the end of the first
quarter and it's become a big
collectible and and so we you go to
mavscollectables.com log in and you get
your free nft and this is my dirk nft
t-shirt that we we um sold
how much
how much have you spent for an nft
the most i've spent for an nft is i
think a thousand dollars um but i've got
a really good collection um if you go to
lazy.com cuban you can see all my nfts
um but i like i love nfts now am i
chasing prices no you know it's just
like i'm not an art collector that's
going to chase prices of great art you
know um beauty is definitely in the eye
of beholders of the holder for art and
for nfts but you know it's it's cool
it's fun it's a lot easier than
collecting baseball or trading cards or
basketball cards you know you don't have
to worry about storing them you don't
have to worry about them getting bent
you don't have to worry about your kids
or your dog eating them it's just it's
just a fun way to collect them and
present them good to talk to you as
always mark thank you good luck in the
playoffs thanks dan appreciate it go
mavs
mavs owner mark cuban
some
interesting things there